foreign
[Music]
hello everyone I would like to welcome
you to this single cell data analysis
webinar by kaijin digital insights thank
you so much for joining us today my name
is Andrew Olson I'm the associate
director for our Discovery insights
portfolio and I'll be your host and
moderator for today
today's topic is about single cell data
in the context of biomarker Discovery
and Target identification today you'll
learn about the importance of expert
curation and how to explore cell
resolution data to visualize within and
across data sets in the context of your
biomarker and Target Discovery questions
and experiments
our speaker today is Dr Joe Pearson Joe
works as the global product manager for
kaijin ohmicsoft
before joining omicsoft in 2015 Joe
earned his PhD from the University of
California San Diego and was a postdoc
and research assistant professor at UNC
Chapel Hill studying CIS regulatory
codes during animal development
his presentation is called rapid cross
project single cell rna-seq exploration
for biomarker and Target discovery and
with that I will hand it over to Joe
thank you Andrew
so before we begin I'd like to mention
that these kaijin project products shown
here are intended for molecular biology
applications these products are not
intended for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of a disease
as a brief introduction to kaijin omic
soft our goal is to accelerate biomarker
Discovery by allowing bioinformaticians
and biologists to quickly answer
questions relevant to biomarker and
Target discovery
through our lands platforms we provide
the ability to discover curated disease
relevant omic studies and find
experimentally validated biomarkers by
exploring our collections of over 600
000 samples across 30 databases
and from over 7 600 projects
by exploring these databases you can
reveal meaningful patterns for your
biomarkers across diseases to do things
like answer questions about where the
expression patterns are between normal
and disease samples
you can explore across our data sets and
use the platform to correlate
multi-ohmic data and the extensive
clinical metadata that have been curated
and you can use the platform to
interactively explore the data at sample
and now cellular resolution
the platform also allows you to export
the full expression data other omics
data and the metadata so you can perform
your own Downstream analyzes with these
curated data
in addition through our platform you can
explore thousands of pre-computed
statistical comparisons these are
comparisons built on the the various
projects that are found within the the
land databases that are curated to
reveal differential gene expression
between disease versus normal treatment
versus control treatment responsiveness
tissue versus tissue and more
these comparisons can be directly
uploaded into kaijin IPA and you can
also compare your data sets in IPA to
over 90 000 comparisons with IPA
analysis match
the Single Cell lens that I'll be
telling you about today are really just
an extension of our existing collection
of lens and our Lan platforms
as with our other lands the the goal is
to enable two key workflows to either
explore across the projects to discover
relevant data sets or to explore by your
biomarkers and find those projects that
are most relevant to you
as an example you might explore within
the Single Cell lens and start at the
project level and query our extensive
curated metadata to filter down and
regroup and organize the data to find
the exact data sets and the relevant
projects that you're looking for
for those projects you can explore the
Deep curated metadata directly
overlaying on Dimension reduction plots
and discover the specific data sets that
are relevant and investigate the
individual clusters that have been
curated
as part of our curation process we
perform pre-computed comparisons between
each cluster and all other clusters
within the dimension reduction plots
and so you can explore these
differential expression results to
identify the top up regulated genes
within each of those clusters
and then you can directly explore the
expression of those at the cellular
level on Dimension reduction plots with
gene expression overlays
[Music]
the other key workflow that our
interface supports is the gene-based
exploration view perhaps you've
identified some candidate biomarkers
from your internal research studies or
by exploring disease land and Uncle land
and the extensive studies there and you
want to dig further into these results
and understand the cellular context of
these gene expression patterns and so
you can start with a gene and explore
across all of the different projects
that have been curated within single
cell lens and look for cross-project
expression
organized across the different tissues
diseases curated cell types and more
organized on any of the curated metadata
you can also search for your Gene of
interest and look for upregulation and
down regulation of your Gene of interest
within each curated cluster but the
differential expression bubble plot
and then you can also finally inspect
your gene expression patterns at the
cellular level on any of the projects
and then take these data and download
the full expression data sets along with
the curated metadata and explore further
the key principle behind our single cell
lens framework is to enable
cross-project exploration and so this
requires several key steps in our
curation process to uh to enable this
you're able to group filter and explore
the gene expression details for
individual studies and across studies
because of our consistent terminologies
that are used during our manual curation
process we use controlled vocabularies
that are compatible with disease land
and oncoland terms and we curate dozens
of different parameters available for
different studies
during our curation process we reprocess
the data from raw files all the way
through alignment quantification quality
control steps and differential
expression analysis using consistent
pipelines so you can compare more
readily across the different studies
our platform allows Dynamic filtering
and grouping on any of the metadata
curated at the project level
the sample level or the manually curated
cell types identified for each cell
cluster
so you can explore the individual data
sets in detail looking at this
collection of similar data sets with
similar cell types or you can combine
them together and visualize them
side by side integrated on any of the
curated metadata
we have data sets available for both
non-umi and Umi data sets and we have
data sets curated on human and mouse
through the interface
you can explore the curation at the
project the sample and the cluster level
as an example of some of the project
level metadata we curate you can see
here that we've curated the project IDs
the technical parameters such as the the
platform and the PubMed ID
the basic study type as well as the
overall theme of the study such as the
therapeutic area and the disease so you
can quickly find studies that you might
be interested in based on the theme
you can also explore these studies at
the sample level what are the contents
of the the experiments that were
performed
so over here we can see on the right a
number of samples from a type 2 diabetes
experiment and with each sample we've
curated a disease state
the tissue source as well as
extensive clinical parameters for each
biological sample and the technical
parameters used
but you can also dig deeper into these
data sets and look at the actual curated
cell types that were identified within
each of these samples
by exploring the the cluster level
metadata
you can see here down at the bottom
right
one dimension production analysis
comprised of several samples
and we've curated nine different
clusters colored here
I've highlighted cluster 4 and cluster
five because as part of our curation
process our biologists identified that
both of these clusters belong to
pancreatic beta cells curated here and
labeled up at the top right
but through the interface you can also
change the expression the overlay and
look at the clinical parameters such as
disease state to reveal that one cluster
cluster four is populated primarily of
pancreatic beta cells from normal
control whereas the other cluster
cluster five is populated primarily from
type 2 diabetes
you can overlay any of the clinical
parameters such as gender shown here or
any any of the other available
and so this allows you to discover
today's sets with your cell types of
Interest or overlay any of the metadata
to reveal patterns and differences
between clusters and guide your
exploration of these data sets and look
for those interesting patterns
to take a step back and introduce you to
how kyogen omisoft curates single cell
data
our data sets are requested by our
customers
and our curators inspect each data set
request and consider it for for
inclusion within our database based on a
number of parameters first of all is the
project compatible with our platform
are all of the key metadata available
for integrating these data into the
platform and make it interpretable and
discoverable within the platform
and are the results actually
interpretable between the data submitted
to the repository and from the The
Source publication or was this just a
data dump
after the metadata inspection our
bioinformaticians inspect the actual
data and make sure that all of the data
that are supposed to be deposited into
the repository were actually available
and If those data are available is the
data submission complete did they
include all of the necessary uh metadata
to to parse the data and processes such
as barcodes
umis and so forth
if the data set passes these Q these
initial QC steps our biologist
use an extensive curation process to
clean up the the metadata and centralize
and organize all of the the metadata
including curating at the project level
the sample level
the technical parameters used for the
experiment as well as any of the
clinical parameters available from the
the data submission into the repository
as well as
clinical and Sample parameters that
might be found within the paper itself
in addition our curators review the
paper and identify the key expected
results for these data sets including
what are the cell types that should be
discovered within the the different
analyzes what are the samples that
should be compared together in dimension
reduction analyzes what are the number
of clusters that should be observed in
the output from from our analysis and in
addition we notif note which are the key
difference to the express genes and
markers that are key to revealing the
different cell types that the authors
are expecting from these data sets
at the same time our bioinformaticians
download the raw data and pass these
data through a full
analysis process
from alignment
quantification
post-processing QC
followed by Dimension reduction analysis
on the relevant data sets and clustering
using unsupervised clustering
and then perform statistical comparisons
between each identified cluster and all
other clusters within the dimensional
reduction analysis
these data are then used by the
biologists for a last round of curation
where for each cluster identified the
curators take the set of expected marker
genes and inspect this in an overlay of
the the Clusters and use this
information to identify the cell type
identity using our control vocabularies
of each of those clusters
and so this means that you can explore
all of our curated data sets and
discover the relevant data sets based on
precise and manual curation of the cell
types that are included
you can filter down on our data sets and
explore and discover based on Project
level metadata
sample level metadata and a curated cell
type metadata
and in the future we are planning to
include additional metadata about how
our curators actually approach the
curation process and identify these key
markers for the for the different cell
types so you have extensive metadata to
help you in interpreting these data sets
in addition you have access to the full
expression data as well as the
pre-computed statistical comparisons
so how might you use this in data
discovery
within the platform let's say that
you're interested in liver data sets you
can start with our filters on the left
side left hand side and filter down on
any of the curated metadata for example
the tissue category filtering down only
for uh
for samples that are from the liver here
we can see multiple data sets from liver
from multiple projects identified from
the GSE number
and you can see that our statisticians
computed multiple Dimension reduction
analyzes and our curators went through
each of these clusters and identified
the cell types for each of these
clusters which we can explore here
for example if you're interested in
hepatocytes you can quickly discover
that the hepatocytes were identified in
this data set
this data set and this data set
and you can identify it through our
interactive plotting explore the details
in the metadata details at the project
sample and the cell cluster level and
you can change the overlay of this
information
on any of the the metadata that have
been curated
okay
as I mentioned before
our statisticians perform
comparisons between each cluster and all
other clusters within the dimension
reduction analysis so you can explore
these comparisons directly
in this example again we're looking for
hepatocytes and we're interested in what
are the key difference the express genes
within hepatocytes compared to the other
cells that you might find within a liver
so we filter down on only comparisons
having to do with liver and we found out
of the over 100 statistical comparisons
generated
we found those where the the case group
of cells were hepatocytes and found 12
different statistical comparisons
between a cluster that was identified as
a parasite and other clusters within the
data set
we can quickly go from
this comparison distribution View and
directly explore those full differential
expression results to identify those top
biomarkers that are upregulated in in
hepatocytes
we're looking at two of the 12
differential expression results from two
different studies and we can see by the
interactive plotting that I've selected
some of the top biomarkers here for one
comparison finding some candidates for
for hepatocyte specific expression
including mat 1A
and we can see those same genes were
automatically selected in the volcano
plot results for another comparison so
these look like some pretty promising
candidates for hepatocyte specific
expression they're consistent among
multiple data sets with hepatocytes
you can inspect this further at the
cellular level
for example looking at that that top
biomarker mat1a we can directly overlay
this on the dimension reduction plots
themselves and compare this to the
metadata that have been curated
here we can see from those same multiple
Dimension reduction analyzes we found
our hepatocytes this cluster these
clusters here in this cluster and we can
see that our Gene mat1a pretty precisely
is labeling those exact same cell types
but we can see some interesting
differences as well for example
this cluster down here was also
identified as candidate hepatocytes but
doesn't have the expression so you might
want to inspect what are the differences
between these hepatocytes and these and
then there's this other type of cell an
epham positive liver cell that
nonetheless has very specific expression
of of mat1a so there's lots of
information here that can be dissected
and explored further to help really
understand these data sets in detail
to take another example perhaps you're
interested in in macrophages that uh
that might be expressed in a multitude
of different tissues including liver
using the extensive metadata you can
regroup the violin plot looking for a
gene such as hmlx1
and organize it too to help understand
and make sense of the data sets that you
found
so in this example we've regrouped on
the cluster cell type so we see the
specific manually curated cell type of
multiple types of macrophages including
M1 and M2 macrophages as well as the
tissue resident cut for cells that are
found in liver
and in addition we've subgrouped these
based on the tissue that they were found
in such as liver lung and ileal mucosa
and then to help see the consistency of
this expression we can also subgroup
further on the source project here where
we've brought together four different
data sets into a single plot
you can search for multiple genes and
look for the consistency and the
similarity and differences of expression
on any of the metadata that you're
interested in
you can filter for projects samples and
cell types of interest and group on any
of the metadata and look for those those
similarities for example these were the
outcome of an IPA analysis of of
macrophages and we're checking out some
candidate biomarkers for for macrophages
here
and so we can see that some genes are
highly specific for a subtype of
macrophages whereas some others are more
broadly expressed across multiple types
you can take this analysis even further
and search for dozens of genes and
explore for example the up regulation
and down regulation pattern of uh
signatures for macrophages across all of
the different statistical comparisons
and look for those patterns of
expression
of upregulation or down regulation in
different data sets across the different
projects across the different tissues
and across the different cell types so
you can identify specific patterns and
you can make unexpected discoveries
about
expression patterns in in cell types you
may not have been unexpected
and with that I'd be happy to take any
questions
great thank you so much Joe that was a
wonderful presentation we do have a
couple questions here
um first one here are are the
visualizations you showed available in
the almost single cell Lan platform
yes yes all of those were screenshots
from the the actual application
cool
and uh is there a limit to the number of
different single cell data sets you
could compare
uh no I mean the the more you filter
down the the more slightly the response
time will be but you can explore the
full data set or you can pre-filter on
any of the individual data sets
gotcha all right great
and
um
can users of the Single Cell lens
framework gain access to the raw or
underlying data either
project by project or through a data
dump or API
yes absolutely so one of the the key
features that we have is the ability to
explore the database and use this as the
the starting point the hub for
discovering data sets and uh and then
you can click on any project you're
interested and with a click download
the the date the full data sets
including the the raw and the normalized
expression values the the metadata and
the differential expression results into
an omeself project and then you can then
export individual data sets for your
Downstream analysis
got it wow that sounds really convenient
um okay uh here I've got kind of a
two-part question
um do you offer
um
let me let me back up let me ask it a
different way
um is it possible to add your own data
into the Single Cell Lan framework
with our service team at kaijin digital
insights they can build single cell data
as well as bulk data and any number of
different data sets into the lens
framework for for exploration okay and
so kind of the follow-up to that would
uh was do you offer any kind of single
cell analysis pipeline if one wanted to
um you know compare their data
yes uh kaijin digital insights has
multiple single cell pipelines you can
use the uh the kaijin digital insights
platforms and and algorithms or the
services team can wrap your custom
pipeline into uh pipeline scripts that
can be run directly through omicsoft
got it okay cool
um so then I have one last question here
and that is uh can you explain what the
advantages are of manual curation versus
AI or machine learning based approaches
yeah
single cell data are tough it's huge
amounts of data lots of different
metadata sourced from a variety of
different data sources different tissues
different experimental standards and and
methods of curation and the source
authors may be interested in very
different projects they use different
terms there's no control on the
terminology and mistakes happen when you
deposit data
and so really the only way to really
explore the data and be able to
understand it properly is to have
consistent deep biological expertise
applied to the the curation process
great all right well I think that's it
for the questions here today I thank
everybody for joining us in today's for
today's webinar and uh again thank you
to our speaker Dr Joe Pearson uh if you
have any questions please visit our
website at
digitalinsights.caijin.com and with that
we wish you uh the best uh for the
remainder of your day today thank you
and we wish you the best for the